das ist eine gefährliche fahrt das
wissen jarek und sein kollege von der
hilfsorganisation rostock schoss und
doch wagen sie es immer wieder rein in
den don was menschen raus holen die es
alleine nicht raus schaffen
[Musik]
wir holen jetzt drei personen ich weiß
dass eine unter ihnen ein mann ohne
beine ist der von zwei älteren frauen
begleitet wird sie haben eine kollegin
angerufen und sie hat es ja nicht
weitergeleitet wir sind jetzt auf dem
weg dorthin wenn die sicherheitslage es
irgendwie zulässt fahren sie los so nah
dran wie möglich an die umkämpften
städte an die front
wir haben jetzt bereits vier fünf
checkpoints passiert seit wir aus diplom
aus sind es ist verboten sie zu filmen
das sind strategische objekte es ist
wichtig dass man nicht sieht wo genau
sie sich befinden
jahre kommt aus china fest eigentlich
flugzeug ingenieur als der krieg anfang
hat er sich gemeldet um als freiwilliger
zu helfen
das ist glaube ich unsere großmutter die
dort sitzt wollen sie nach colonia wir
sind hier für sie
ihr mann pedro sitzt seit jahren im
rollstuhl
die beiden kommen aus einem kleinen dorf
in der region bonn jetzt dass von den
russen besetzt wurde sie waren mit die
letzten die die ukrainische armee
evakuiert und weg gebracht hat von der
front als der krieg ihr dorf erreicht
hatte
sie und ihre nachbarin lidia die alles
verloren hat im februar hat sie ihren
sohn beerdigt der andere gilt seit
kriegsbeginn als vermisst
wir haben dort 21 tage das grauen erlebt
jetzt dass dort jetzt
es dort nichts mehr die häuser sind alle
zerstört
[Musik]
unerbittlich gnadenlos rücken die russen
im don was vor melden eroberung nach
eroberung in einer region in der seit
2014 schon krieg herrscht mittlerweile
sagen die ukrainischen behörden sind 80
prozent der zivilbevölkerung aus der
region bonn jetzt geflohen
[Musik]
sie werden jetzt region luhansk ein ort
der zum symbol geworden ist für den
schier aussichtslosen kampf der ukraine
die russen haben wichtige brücken
zerstört die meisten einwohner sind
geflohen aber noch immer wird gekämpft
auch weiß sie werden jetzt strategisch
so wichtig ist
[Musik]
libro die größte stadt in der ost
ukraine ist so etwas wie die erste
anlaufstelle für alle die aus den
umkämpften gebieten fliehen
nach drei stunden fahrt haben es auch
pedro lidia und die anderen erst mal
hierher geschafft ins zentrum eine
anlaufstelle für kranke und menschen mit
beeinträchtigungen sergej und seine frau
elena die ms hat sind gerade noch aus
ihrer heimatstadt rausgekommen
jetzt gerade fährt schon überhaupt
niemand mehr nach sevilla
dort wird aktuell gekämpft mir tun die
menschen so leid die immer noch da sind
wie ist so was nur möglich
den schwächsten zu helfen eine
anlaufstelle zu sein das haben sie sich
hier auf die fahnen geschrieben
olga wolkowa war schnell klar dass ich
sonst keiner kümmern würde
als der krieg anfing habe ich gesehen
wie die menschen evakuiert wurden das
waren menschenmassen die da auf die
waggons losstürmt und mir war sofort
klar dass eine person mit einer
behinderung ist nie da hinein schaffen
wird und das ist ein sehr großes problem
das vom staat nicht gelöst wurde erst
jetzt kommt bewegung in die sache
tief im westen der ukraine im sport
läuft die hilfe zusammen bei den
ehrenamtlichen von rostock schoss fast
alle sind selbst vor dem krieg
geflüchtet es sind studentinnen schüler
bankkauffrauen theaterdirektoren mehr
als 20.000 menschen haben sie schon
evakuiert aber manchmal können auch sie
einfach nichts mehr tun
ich verstehe sie absolut meine
großmutter ist auch noch in den
besetzten gebieten
es gibt einfach nichts was wir tun
können die busse und autos die noch in
die besetzten gebiete in die region
lohans gefahren sind sie wurden einfach
beschossen die gefahr ist zu groß
zurzeit
entschuldigen sie bitte dass ich ihn
einfach nicht helfen kann
auf wiedersehen passen sie auf sich auf
er hat gesagt verstehen sie mich denn
nicht und ich was die ihn doch nur zu
gut meine oma ist doch dort
jetzt
es gibt keine verbindungen
danach ganz selten
[Musik]
wenn nico organisiert jahres schon
seinen nächsten einsatz er will helfen
solange er gebraucht wird und solange
das niveau noch möglich ist denn auch
hier gibt es luftalarm gehen nachts die
lichter aus angst vor russischen
angriffen